Hello and welcome to
fire of learning coffee,
one of the world's most
valued commodities.
The 25 million people employed in
the coffee industry in some form,
produced a 9.3 million tons of coffee
beans worldwide each year and help turn it
into the 500 billion cups of coffee.
We consume yearly in a
variety of ways and styles.
All this consumption has made coffee
the second most traded commodity in the
world after oil,
but the drink that some of us now feel
that we need every day was not always
there.
In fact,
it's a recent addition to
the world compared with many
other drinks and products.
The relationship between coffee and
people has more humble origins as a wild
plant here in east Africa today,
Ethiopia,
the story of coffee begins in the ninth
century and there are legends that an
Ethiopian goat herder named Caldy noticed
it as goats had become very energetic
after having consumed the berries,
have a strange plant,
which we now know to be
coffee berries called.
He then tried the berries and after
having been surprised by the enjoyable,
energetic feeling that came,
brought them to a nearby Islamic
monk who first tried to burn them and
disapproval,
but then noticed a pleasurable smell
coming from the seeds from within the
roasted coffee berries and then ground
up and dissolve the emmers into water,
creating the first cup of coffee from
their coffee spread across these Islamic
world.
The story was almost certainly made up
perhaps a thousand years or so after its
claim to take place,
but it's probably true that Ethiopians
had discovered the unique effects of the
barriers of the cafe. A plant around
the time that the legend takes place,
the knowledge of this
and the beans themselves,
which aren't technically beans by the way,
just look alikes.
They're seasoned fact probably soon
enter the nearby Islamic world within a
century or so though the actual drink
we know and love would not be made for a
few centuries to come.
That story takes place across the Red
Sea and a country none then and now as
Yemen.
The stimulating effects of coffee beans
were possibly first described by an
Arabic polymath named
Muhammad ibn Zachariah.
I'll Razi or more simply Rosie's
around 900 a d though it was definitely
mentioned by the Persian polymath
I Ali [inaudible] or [inaudible].
Later that century,
around this time period,
Islamic monks began cultivating a plant
and turning the fermenting berries into
a kind of wine,
none as Kesher.
The first evidence of coffee as the
drink we know made similarly to how it is
made today in fact,
comes from the 14 hundreds it is not
known who first invented it or where
exactly it was invented.
Some ambiguous reports say it was a
Muslim chic named Jamal, all dean,
all the Bonnie and 1454 but the first
clear reports of it come from Sufi Muslim
monks again in Yemen who used a drink
to stay awake the night for religious
purposes.
It would then be spread rapidly across
the Arabian peninsula and into the rest
of these Islamic world.
By the year of 1500 people were drinking
coffee from North Africa to Turkey to
Persia, all originating from
the Yemeni port. City of Mocha.
I named carried with coffee to this day.
The meanies would take great
care to protect their trade,
requiring all coffee beans to be boiled
and sterilized before it can be shipped
out to foreign lands. Though
of course, as we shall see,
it would not be protected forever.
No one knew it then of course,
but the stimulating effects,
which may coffees or popular come
from a drug within it. Caffeine,
caffeine like nicotine and morphine in
fact evolved in the end susters of the
cafe. A plant as a way to
keep insects from eating it.
Insects which consumed a plant were
killed by the effects of caffeine. So yes,
Caffeine essentially originated
as an insecticide. Thankfully,
it's effects on humans and
other animals are less toxic.
It's stimulating effects on humans come
firstly from the fact that it mimics a
chemical release in our brains
known as adenosine. Simply put,
as we go about our days
and energy is released,
adenosine builds up in our brains.
The more identizine which builds up
the sleepier, you get as of course,
as process signals to your brain as you
had been using energy. Caffeine, however,
is molecularly very similar to identizine
and it's capable of binding to the
adenosine receptors in the brain,
but it's not similar enough to activate
them just to block the identizine from
the receptors and therefore prevents you
from feeling the tiredness that you'd
actually be feeling.
The world's most consumed drug
does more than just this though.
It's effects also lead to an increase
of adrenaline which increases heart rate
blood flow and creates
a feeling of energy.
It also helps release
dopamine which improves mood.
All of these factors encouraged.
The popularity of a drink is one which
improves mood, energy, focus and thinking.
However,
as I said,
no one at the time knew anything about
this as caffeine wouldn't be identified.
In fact until 1819 by the German chemists,
free league,
Ferdinand Ruena throughout
the 16th century coffee.
We continue to gain popularity in the
Middle East with mixed reception's not
everyone,
particularly Orthodox Islamic and moms
liked it and its effects along with the
fact that coffee houses in the Middle
East typically allowed prostitution,
astrology, and other things which
weren't necessarily appreciated by Islam,
led to it being banned and multiple
places on several occasions such as Mecca
and 1511 and Cairo and 1532 but it was
too late for the opponents of coffee.
As many including powerful
leaders like the Ottoman Sultan,
Suleiman the first had
already taken a liking to it.
Leaders like Solomont across the Islamic
world overturned many of these bands
and press for copies.
Acceptance in Islam,
coffee began to reach
Europe a few decades later.
Europeans first reportedly encountered
coffee on the island of Malta where the
knights of Saint John
Having taken Ottoman Turks,
slaves during the great siege of Malta,
founders slaves repairing a drink and
try it, some of it for themselves.
And 1565 in 1573 coffee was described
by a traveling botanists and physician
named Laonard rivals who called Shaba.
While in Aleppo,
he wrote a beverage as black as inc
useful against numerous illnesses,
particularly those at the stomach.
It's consumers take it in the morning,
quite frankly in a porcelain cup that
has passed around and from which each one
drinks a cupful.
It is composed of water and the fruit
from a Bush called Buena Buena wasn't
named the Ethiopians gave to the
plant which was described in Arabic.
Though the Arabic word for coffee at the
time was cowatch not long after in the
1580s and nineties as the Venetians
began increasing a trade with the Muslim
world, coffee found its way
to mainland Europe from Italy,
the Arabic word Koala became Covey in
Turkish and Italian became cafe and French
cafe and other languages took on similar
names becoming coffee and English as in
the Muslim world. The Christian world
also reacted hesitantly to coffee.
Many people enjoyed it and it spread
rapidly through the continent,
but many criticize it, calling it a Muslim
drink or even a better drink of Satan.
Debate would last over the drink until
about 1600 when Pope Clement the eighth
who his reign was marked by
conflict with the Muslim Turks,
tried the drink and light enough
to declare it a Christian drink.
Throughout the 16 hundreds coffee became
a hot commodity in Europe and many
trading companies focused on importing it.
Coffeehouses opened up across Europe,
the first one on mainland Europe outside
the Ottoman Empire being in Venice in
1645 the Yemenis had tried to
safeguard the production of coffee,
but of course failed in their endeavors.
Attempts to smuggle live coffee seeds
out of Yemen and creased in 1616 of the
Dutch succeeded in doing it and attempted
to grow the plant in their homeland
and in their colonies in modern day Sri
Lanka and Java and would later focus on
the production in the East indies.
The Dutch would begin to spread coffee.
Third Trade to places like Japan
as well. The plant, of course,
prefers a tropical climate and 60th
70th Sophie monk smuggled several coffee
beans from Yemen to India
and to the Kingdom of Mysore
where the plants grew and
not only successfully remain there,
but allow the plant and a drink to be
eventually successfully spread across the
world.
From the Americas to the east.
Assisting the spread was
the failed siege of Vienna,
where in the victorious European
forces looting Ottoman camps,
discovered coffee beans that
had been brought with them.
They'll coffee had been declared a
Christian drink and spread across Europe
rapidly.
Coffeehouses were a different story.
It's perhaps ironic that the introduction
of coffee to Europe correlated closely
with the age of enlightenment,
but it is indeed true that
many enlightenment thinkers
across Europe met at
coffee houses to discuss a number
of topics including social,
political and religious reform. The famous
French enlightenment thinker Voltaire,
for example, is said to have drank
up to 80 cups of coffee a day.
The monarchs of Europe would attempt to
crack down on seditious and rebellious
talk and activity during the
enlightenment. Some such as Charles.
The second of England would
target these coffee houses,
specifically closing many of them down.
The French Naval Officer Gabrielle declaw
is often credited with having spread
coffee plants to the Americas in 1720
accounts telephone him nurturing a coffee
plant during a voyage, sharing
his water ration with it. In fact,
until he was able to plant it in a French
colony of Martinique where it came to
be the ancestor of huge amounts of the
coffee plants grown today. However,
we now know that coffee was growing into
French colonies. A sound a mean now,
modern day Heidi and the Dutch colony
of Suriname just a few years prior.
Regardless, Duclos efforts are an
important moment in coffee history.
The production of coffee though having
many different methods across the world,
essentially boils down to the same steps
and has since its creation and Yemen.
Coffee, as I said, originates from
the cafe trees. Within a few years,
the tree begins producing
fruits known as Coffee Cherries.
These trees can live to be up to six
years old when the cherries are ready.
The seeds are separated from the first
through a variety of methods. These seeds,
as aforementioned are the coffee beans
there are left to dry out in the sun and
then a coding none.
As parchment is removed,
the seeds are then roasted and then
ground up at the end of this process.
One is left with coffee grounds,
right to make coffee with.
While coffee had become popular in Europe,
it's still also has to compete with tea
and alcohol and a number of other drinks.
In colonial America in particular,
it was not very popular at first.
That is of course until the 1770s during
the revolutionary war when t became a
product,
very much associated with Britishness.
I'm sure a fellow American viewers can
think of famous incidents such as the
Boston tea party. As an example,
coffee became a popular alternative.
However, it was in short supply and
prices rose considerably. Nevertheless,
from the foundation of the country,
protests of tea and the coffee becoming
what is culturally seen as America's
choice of caffeine,
though rather popular now and
spread across five continents,
coffee was still not exactly
cheap and was available regularly.
Only still wealthier and the ability
that would begin to change. However,
in the 19th century following Brazil's
independence from Portugal and 1822
expanding the coffee industry was very
much seen as an opportunity to encourage
the new nation's economic growth.
It did so I'll be it unfortunately in
the beginning from the work of slaves
which led to Brazil being the last western
nation to outlaw slavery in 1888 but
Brazil's coffee had led the coffee
becoming a drink of the masses or in other
words, a cup of Joe. Once
coffee production is plentiful,
people were quick to regularly consume it.
A trend which never went away,
it would be a breakfast food for average
citizens are recreational drink fuel
for the productiveness of the world
for soldiers and laborers as well as
philosophers and scientists I drink,
which was made in the Arabian peninsula
from the seeds of plant found in
Ethiopia, is now regularly consumed
and available across the world.
To this day,
Brazil remains the number one producer
of coffee in the world producing about a
third of all the world's
coffee or about 3 million tons.
It is followed by Vietnam and second
place at one and a half million tons,
Columbia and third with 750,000
Indonesia and fourth at 640,000 tons and
Ethiopia, the home of the coffee
plant in fifth place at 470,000 tons.
The two main varieties of coffee
grown our Arabica and Robusta.
These major producers along with many
other significant producers unsurprisingly
are located in a region of the earth,
ideal for the growth and health of the
cafe. A plant known as the coffee belt.
Coffee has never been more diversified
than it is today with many kinds and
tastes.
Many additions like milk or to use the
Italian word for milk Latte as well as
cream and sugar originated in Europe
in the 17th and 18th centuries.
From these simple combinations,
coffee and its varieties
would diversify greatly.
There are even now coffee flavored
things like coffee flavored ice cream and
cake.
A common kind of coffee is decaffeinated
coffee as you might guess for the name
coffee without caffeine or in reality,
just a small amount of caffeine.
The process of removing caffeine from
coffee was discovered in 1903 by accident
by a German merchant named Ludvig.
Rebellious Caffeine is removed from
the unroasted beans using solvents or a
times just water. It is not made from
the roots of the plant economists.
The amount of caffeine in a cup of coffee
is usually about 95 milligrams per cup
or per eight ounces. Though it of
course varies greatly. Comparatively,
there are anywhere from 70
to 115 milligrams of caffeine
in a cup of an average
energy drink, 40 milligrams in an
average cup of tea, 40 milligrams,
and a cup of most soda beverages in
about five milligrams in decaf coffee.
Plain coffee itself is
not really nutritious,
but the caffeine in it carries a
number of health effects. As I said,
the drug has a number
of effects on people.
Generally these are positive
increasing energy, focus, attention,
mood and motivation.
Though for many,
most notably people with anxiety disorders
though those without them as well.
Sometimes it can be negative as an
increase in adrenaline and other factors
create anxiety, nervousness,
jitteriness and his comfort.
The higher the dose of caffeine.
The more one is at risk developing these
symptoms as well as sweating insomnia,
indigestion, headaches and
nausea, scientific studies.
How predominantly shown however,
that a normal consumption of coffee,
even a few cups every day,
is not detrimental to the health
of the average person. Further,
a specific study on coffee is lacking.
However,
studies suggests that coffee consumption
may extend your life and improve
brainpower.
However,
it is not known exactly which illnesses
are staved off or how exactly this is
done and only also a general doses.
Regular excessive consumption of coffee
may have a negative effect on lifespan.
While a coffee may not
affect cancer much other way,
it may be good for heart diseases.
It is also possible that copy's slightly
lowers the risk of type two diabetes,
dementia and Parkinson's disease and
as an appetite suppressant may help you
lose weight. It May, however, lead
to an increased risk of dry skin,
hypertension, osteoporosis, heart attack,
and may have a 14% increased
risk of lung cancer.
Though this last one only amongst smokers.
As a result of all this.
Caffeine is not recommended for
those with cardiovascular diseases,
anxiety disorders, insomnia,
and other similar conditions.
The exact health effects on pregnant
women have yet to be determined.
This is all quite a bit, but
caffeine is, as I've said,
a fairly safe drug and if not consumed
and excessive amounts likely won't ever
be a problem for most as is
usually the rule with drugs.
The higher you rise, the harder
you fall. Coffee's main ingredient.
Caffeine is not nearly as intense
as other stimulants like cocaine or
amphetamines and its withdrawal symptoms
are likewise much lighter symptoms of
caffeine. Withdrawal, however
typically include headaches, fatigue,
problems with concentration as well
as depressed mood, constipation,
muscle stiffness,
irritability as well as others.
So if you find yourself
wanting to give up coffee,
it might be easier to slowly cut back on
intake and then maybe switch to tea and
then come back on t and so forth to
avoid caffeine. Withdrawal Coffee is,
as I've said,
great for the economy.
It accounts for 63% of Brazil's exports
just as an example and is therefore a
main source of revenue for that
country as well as many others.
It is important to note,
however,
coffee production does have a
negative effect on the environment.
It requires a considerable amount of
water which is problematic for dryer
nations like Ethiopia.
Traditional methods of growing coffee
along trees have also fallen out and its
production increases deforestation
and habitat destruction.
The use of pesticides is further
harmful to the environment.
In fact that up to this point pesticides
have been even more harmful to the
predators of paths and a pest themselves
creates an even bigger issue and all of
these issues will have to be addressed
as the demand for coffee and the strains
on the environment continue to grow.
Whether you're an occasional coffee
drinker needed every day or just have an
interest in subject,
I hope enjoyed this video.
Let me know in the comments section how
much coffee you drink to support the
creation of more videos like these.
A link to our patriotic we found
and a channel subscription.
Any donation would be appreciated and
be put to use to improve the channel.
I will likely be covering the history
and science of other similar commodities
in the future,
as well as making many other videos.
So stay tuned with more videos like this
and videos on many other subjects by
subscribing to fire of learning.
Thank you for watching.